Speaker 1: Let's go to is it west from Salt
Lake City or Wesley? It's sort of cut off.
Speaker 3: Weston.
Speaker 1: Weston, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi. I was wondering what your
thoughts are on something I've observed
with right wing and conservative people is
that they seem to have a very United States
centric worldview. Yes. Like I lived and
I lived in Argentina for two years. And
there was free health care, free college. And
they're much poorer than the United States.
Yes. So and then we have other things like. Sorry.
I'm really nervous. You're doing great. We have,
you know, examples of other countries that are,
you know, comparable GDP or per capita GDP,
and they have much lower gun homicide rates.
And what would you how would you you know,
I guess my thing is, is how do
we convince these people that
these policies are possible free health care,
affordable health care, universal health care or,
you know, college free college that would
help us compete on an international level
as citizens of the world or that we could lower
homicide rate by gun. How do we convince them that
these are possible? Because it seems
like they think it's possible. But
I've seen it. Yeah, it exists in the world.
Speaker 1: The weird, the outlier is actually
the United States on a lot of these issues. It's
the U.S. that has of of the rich countries where
the one that has this wacky health care system
of the rich countries, where the one that has
this amount of gun gun crime and gun violence.
Yeah. No, there's no question about that. I think
it's unfortunately, there's not an easy
answer. A lot of Americans are brought up
never really thinking about the rest of the world.
And they think the United States is just the way
everything is rather than realizing that. It's
sort of like, what's the the allegory of is it
Plato's cave or what? You know, it's this thing
of when if all you ever see are the shadows cast
by what's behind you, you would believe that the
world is made up only of those shadows. And only
when you turn around and you see what is actually
there can you understand kind of what the world
works like. And if you grow up very U.S. centric,
you don't go anywhere else. You don't learn about
any other place. You think the U.S. is, quote,
normal and everything else is weird. But the U.S.
is actually the outlier in in so many of these
different ways. I think it's an educational thing
at the bottom. At the bottom. Bottom line.
Speaker 3: Yeah. It almost contradicts
their world view that the United States is
exceptional in every way. Right. You know,
we're underperforming in all of these areas
and that we really are exceptional. Can't we
do better than these other countries?
Speaker 1: Yeah, in many ways,
the U.S. is exceptional among rich countries
in how bad some indicators are among rich,
rich countries. Infant mortality is much
higher than in many other wealthy countries.
And gun violence is obviously off the charts.
And the degree of inequality is off the charts.
Percentage of children living in poverty,
all all these different things. And it's
a real uphill battle to climb. I don't know
that there's one way to enlighten everybody.
Hello. All right. Thank you. I think we've lost
you, but I very much appreciate the call. And
that is going to do it for calls for today. I'm
so glad I was able to speak to so many of you.
I will take calls again and I hope to hear
from you next time. We'll take a quick break
and be back right after this.